it's like 7:30 at night I'm drinking
coffee hi guys my name is Tara chambers
and this is Tara's never seen I've a
tattoo now my parents don't know about
it yet so hopefully they don't watch
this hi mom hi dad if you do watch this
don't read the comments they're so bad I
was home for Christmas and I showed my
mom one specific comment that I got from
somebody calling me a liar for the whole
series but he was like fuming about home
alone first of all it's hilarious second
of all I showed my mom and she was
horrified because it's horrifying
people think I'm lying about not seeing
these movies anyways today I'm doing
pulp fiction who wants to challenge me
let's go in a lazy movie viewer I don't
have a humongous passion for the unknown
movies wise I guess I like content that
I'm familiar with and I don't know this
is it's been on Netflix forever so we
all get to it whenever and that makes me
miss out on a bunch of like really
badass movies that I'm sure I'm going to
love like I am going to adore this movie
I love love Quentin Tarantino like I
think I've seen all of his stuff yes
hateful eight yes Django yes sing Gloria
spaz turds no Reservoir Dogs no Jackie
Brown no Kill Bill Line tube yes Kill
Bill volume 1 which is one of my
favorite movies yes grindhouse no true
romance no four rooms no natural-born
killers yes Sin City there's a Kill Bill
Vol three no to happen so I guess I
haven't seen 5000 cameras never seen ok
I knew that I was going to love this
movie I knew it from the bottom of my
heart but guess what guys I loved this
movie I loved the he combines all these
little stories he does that a lot and
then you get the titles and it's just it
just all intertwined so well I loved it
I loved it I loved it I loved it so
there's this amazing start where Tim
Roth and this other actress oh I know
I've seen places what is her name
Amanda plum plumber plumber plumber I
think what I seen her what is she minute
I know I could Google this yeah though
she's super
quirky IO actually like that term for
actresses because quirky has now become
Zooey Deschanel I think sometimes people
get like cornered and like pigeon holed
into like a certain type like okay
Johnny Depp who is now just like this
crazy you know what I'm talking about I
think it's the same thing with Zooey
Deschanel when people say quirky that's
what I think of but she this actress was
super quirky and like nutso but in the
best way I loved her they want to rob
restaurants and they're in a restaurant
and so they decide to rob at this
restaurant and it just cuts away to do
here flips can do fun bumps what if I
have so it cuts to John Travolta and
samuel l.jackson you can tell that they
can annoyed with each other really
easily but it's like this brotherly
annoyance their conversations in this
whole movie are excellent your
friendship is so great and I love that
they're BFFs
for life best friend for life for life
and he's like you know what's great
about Europe little differences pretty
much all the saves the little
differences that are great that's true I
just I was just in Europe for the first
time and I agree with you sir Sir John
Travolta king of Greece he's like yeah
yeah McDonald's you can buy a beer
hahaha I love it that's his example I am
the foot massage master
Marcellus Wallace is the boss of the BFF
team and he's also just this giant what
drug lord just a badass gangster just
like a cool powerful guy who's intense
is a bandaid on his his neck so
Marcellus bribes Bruce Willis who is a
boxer to lose a fight so that he can
then bet against him and then like win a
bunch of money I guess I don't know how
boxing works I don't like it it stresses
me out
so John Travolta Vincent does heroin and
then goes and takes out his boss
Marcellus ah's wife Mia who is uma
Thurman who I have
a giant girl crash on and I didn't see
Kill Bill for a long time because I
thought that it was um I don't know why
but in my mind it was Joe Dirt
don't ask me guys I no idea why I
thought that but I thought the Kill Bill
was Joe Dirt and I had seen Joe Dirt the
guy with like the mullet you know I'm
talking about I had seen pictures of him
and looks like I have no interest in
that I want want to watch that my friend
was like what this is gonna be your
favorite movie of all time but yeah I
love uma it's what this is that's a
weird position to put your employee in
because if she enjoys it too much then
you're in trouble if she doesn't enjoy
it enough then you're in trouble so it's
got to be like this right mix of like
we're vibe in here but not too much not
too much vibes this is weird it's not
weird so they go to the 50s version of
the rainforest cafe and at that point I
googled when this movie was set it's
like it's a sentence 70 this question I
couldn't tell you know it's guys like I
kind of really weird stylized which
Quentin Tarantino does a lot they don't
have a specific year for when it's it
but um everyone speculates this the
early 90s both of them are high they're
both of this 50s restaurant he's high on
heroin she just went into the bathroom
to powder her nose which means taking a
shit to the coke so they enter this
dance contest which is hilarious and
awkward like okay grace King give it you
awkward man have you guys seen that
picture of the dog that looks just like
john travolt
it was just like a lot of this and a lot
of like like do this so they get back to
her house at Marcellus house and she
pulls out his heroin which I believe she
thinks his coke so she snorts the heroin
and overdoses that's just such an
intense drug to me I feel like and
they're so casual about it in
which is so quitting Tarantino it's like
yeah well both of you guys are high on a
different intense drug and good luck
I just wrote she thinks heroin his coke
and snorted OD also I forgot and we have
to bleep out my fault so it's me really
lug bleep he drives her to his dealers
house and they give her a shot of
adrenaline into her heart and she limbs
I was like well now this is where the
movies going like now he's gonna get
killed by Marcellus because he killed
his wife and that's just where it's
going that's what's happening great
great no I know what's going on amazing
bitch ethic job that's not what happened
you guys so it cuts to Bruce Willis
waking up from this dream of him being
little getting the watch and instead of
going down in the fight like he's
supposed to he just kills the guy he's
like small change just took artistic
license I killed him so he gets back to
this hotel room where his lover is at
she's a line that she said I couldn't
write it down fast enough but it's
something like it's a shame that what we
like to feel and what we like to see are
usually different no so insightful and
cool I really liked that line and then
he finds out she didn't pack the gold
watch and he freaks the fuck out that
watch has been in a lot of butts you
don't just forget that watch okay so
he's like all right well I gotta be
stealthy so he goes to get his watch and
he finds the watch he's like you know
what I feel like confident I'll make
myself a pop-tart he finds this gun in
his kitchen and then he turns to the
bathroom where the person who owns the
gun is in and of course is convinced
because Vince has a constipation problem
because heroin and he just annihilates
him he totally takes him out shoot Tim's
feeling very confident and he leaves he
gets in his car he's like hell yeah
doing great butch runs into Marcellus
and then crashes into something and then
like there's this whole like foot chase
and then they wind up in this weird pawn
shop and then the pawn shop owner pulls
out his own gun
and pointed at Marcela's and Bruce and
is like don't know you're not gonna
shoot anybody in my store and at that
point I was like hell yeah pawn shop
owner I feel that don't shoot anybody by
Stewart
I'll get who's on whose side doesn't
matter but then you find out that he's a
piece of shit he's like an actual piece
of shit who's like holding him captive
oh so encounter Lola but like in AD this
is the story so well it was such a twist
in the story that I was not expecting
you it's like not even a little bit it's
like no one kills anybody in my shop
except for me instead well I guess we're
gonna meet dead soon then Zed shows up
butch escapes and then he's like you
know what this is gonna be wise for me
to do and kind and great as a human so
I'm gonna go back and save Marcellus and
there's this amazing scene of him
picking the weapon he's gonna use so he
picks up a hammer and he's like nah and
they picked up a bat second ah and they
picks up a chain top is it now and then
he picks up a katana so he goes down
saves Marcellus chops a guy and then
like threatens another guy and then
Marcel is like I got this you're excused
for what you did to me leave now so
there's this amazing scene before butch
and his lover leave she's like where'd
you get that motorcycle a stick it's a
chopper and she's like where's my hanta
and he's like so repetitive like he's so
sad he's like I'm sorry baby but I had
to crash at Honda but let's go but so
then after that the whole movie doesn't
like a lot of jumps they jump back to
the first scene where the BFF team is in
that apartment dealing with the guys who
fall over Marcellus so then you see
Marvin who is like their insider who got
them into that apartment and he's
friends with Jules and Marvin is
freaking out they're like come on Marvin
let's go they get in their car and then
Vince accidentally I was going to do
this but like he legitimately
accidentally shoots Marvin in the head
and looking explodes in their car
they're on the freeway in LA
and they're like well not sure what to
do now so they go to their friend's
house who ends up being Quentin
Tarantino they're trying to figure out
what hello watch the hole it was very
nice
so nice I wrote love the dude who comes
to solve their bloody car problem love
him so suave so efficient so they get
everything cleaned up and then they
clean themselves up which explains the
new weird clothes they were in like the
gym shorts and t-shirts that you see in
the beginning of the movie but you don't
know what's happening
cool timeline effect before they go back
to March Alice's place they go get
breakfast and they're in the exact
restaurant that the couple from the
beginning are robbing and I love it so
much I should have called it but I
didn't I was just enjoying it so much so
then everything comes together and the
robbers robbed everyone and they come up
to Jules commences in the bathroom
because of course because heroine and
he's trying to take the case from Jules
and Jules shows him what's in the case
which no one knows what is in the case
and I love that I love an unsolved
mystery in a movie you long to be cool
everyone that you care about in this
movie ends up having a happy life Vince
doesn't but also you have weird lips
Vince so sorry sorry it's the writing is
incredible
the acting is incredible and I love the
timeline aspect of it I've seen every
Quentin Tarantino movie except for pulp
fiction so it's about time that I watch
this and then I watch it it's like oh
it's amazing and then I looked at his
list of movies like oh you haven't seen
any of his movies Tamra a couple but not
maybe yesterday I posted a video on my
personal channel Tamra Lynne chambers at
youtube.com let me go crashing it
bye see you next week
[Music]